ben monsieur bonsoir en ce moment dans
les vestiaires du parc des princes à
paris le coeur de 11 garçons est en
train de battre un peu plus vite et à
l'unisson le coeur de millions de
français
avant cette rencontre france hollande
qui décidera ce soir des chances de
l'équipe de france pour se qualifier ou
non pour la coupe mondiale de football
la rencontre comme vous le savez est
retransmise en direct sur antenne 2
juste après ce journal depuis ce matin
le parc des princes est pris d'assaut
les supporters des deux camps sont en
place et l'ambiance est déjà chaude
j'en amer une journée commencé très tôt
pour les supporters hollandais une
journée pluvieuse coup plutôt arrosée
enfin comme vous voudrez c'est à près de
dix mille
ils sont partis ce matin de différents
points de hollande en bus généralement
l'occasion en chantant de découvrir pour
paris et ses inévitables embouteillages
et ce dès 16h centre de paris
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le parc des
princes
il est 17 heures aux alentours du stade
et le marché noir comme toujours bat son
plein les déplacements
et vous avez payé 30 francs c'est là que
l'on voit passer la nuit j'ai pu elle
devait pas lui vaut le faire
c'est la facture du matin sa fin le
rapport aux 14 18 heures la nuit est
tombée les caps hommes sont bloqués la
france commencent à débarquer une foule
silencieuse venue du métro ou bien riche
en couleurs venus de loin et elle sait
faire savoir 2
et puis il ya des hollandais mais aussi
des belges est eux qui sont fiers de
l'être avec ses lois pour le match
tigana qui place la france gagne là-bas
de 0,2
tout ce beau monde longtemps parquet à
l'entrée du stade vient à peine d'être
libérée mais ce qui importe maintenant
c'est bien sûr d'être chauvin
la tâche promet d'être rude pour les
français c'est un peu de l'honneur
national qu'ils auront au bout du pied
alors thierry rolland l'enjeu on le
connaît un dernier pronostic est ce que
on a une chance à un bien oui christine
j'espère que nous avons une chance je
pense que même nous avons une première
chance est un match
freddy 6,6 sans doute le plus difficile
de toute l'histoire du football
française 100 employés de grands mots et
je pense que le public ne s'y est pas
trompé car sur les images que vous venez
de diffusé sur france 2 jean ma mère est
bien on sent vraiment que toute la
nation est derrière son équipe de
football sertic ne s'agit que d'un match
de football c'est vrai
il ya des choses beaucoup plus
importantes que cela dans la vie d'un
pays ou dans la vie du sport tout
particulièrement mais enfin je pense que
le match de ce soir est très important
et je pense également que l'équipe de
france disputant ce match à paris devant
son public devant un public qui va être
chauffés à blanc à n'en pas douter est
bien l'équipe de france est armé pour
faire ce qu'il faudra pour gagner face à
une équipe qui n'est pas la première
venue il est bon de le répéter une
nouvelle fois puisque les footballeurs
des pays bas ont disputé la finale des
deux derniers championnats du monde et
cela nous permet de rappeler à nouveau
que lorsque le tirage au sort de ces
groupes préliminaire de coupe du monde a
été effectué et bien l'équipe de france
ne pouvait pas plus mal tomber face aux
pays bas deux fois finalistes de la
coupe du monde lors des deux dernières
coupes du monde et face à la belgique
finaliste du dernier championnat
d'europe des nations il fallait donc en
éliminer un des deux fils qu'il n'y
avait que deux qualifiés possible dans
ce groupe est de toute façon réussir en
éliminer l'un des deux était un exploit
que seule l'équipe de france pouvait
réaliser au parc des princes
c'est ce que nous attendons d'elle ce
soir à partir de 20h30 au coup de
sifflet de monsieur garrido l'arbitré
portugais bien série mercy nouveau
retrouvons donc dans 25 minutes très
exactement